>> MURAT: It all starts in your head. No matter where you are.
Das ist Englisch.
Das hört sich einfach cooler an als Deutsch.
Auf Deutsch ganz einfach:
Es ist egal, wo du bist,
ob du in einem kleinen Dorf bist, in einem kleinen Büro,
irgendwo auf dem Land, auf einem Bauernhof.
Es reicht die Idee, um etwas zu erreichen.
[Musik]
Herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es ein Video völlig aus der Reihe.
Es hat nichts mit Kochen, nichts mit Backen zu tun,
sondern es geht um die Geschichte von Sallycon Valley.
Vielleicht habt ihr es ab und zu mal durch meine Postings
auf meiner Instagram-Seite mal mitgekriegt,
dass wir Sallycon Valley bauen schon über ein Jahr.
Keiner weiß eigentlich richtig darüber Bescheid.
Wir wussten es vor einem halben Jahr auch noch nicht richtig,
muss ich ganz, ganz ehrlich sagen.
Und ich möchte euch
die Geschichte von Sallycon Valley erzählen.
Sallycon Valley ist eigentlich genau wie dieser Teich hier.
In diesem Teich befinden sich Fische.
Den habe ich vor zwei Jahren ungefähr angelegt.
Und Fische werden immer nur so groß wie der Teich.
Hast du einen kleinen Teich, hast du kleine Fische.
Wenn du einen größeren Teich hast,
dann werden die Fische größer.
Genauso ist es mit Ideen.
Ideen brauchen Wachstum.
Ideen brauchen Platz, um kreativ zu werden.
Und deswegen bauen wir Sallycon Valley,
um noch mehr Ideen in die Welt zu setzen,
um noch mehr Dinge zu machen,
die vielleicht sogar die Welt verändern können.
Und wir sind in Waghäusel.
Waghäusel ist eine kleine Stadt in Baden.
Und wir kommen nicht aus Berlin,
wir kommen nicht aus München,
wir kommen nicht aus Köln,
wo die ganzen Medien, die Start-ups und die Politik ist,
sondern wir sind wirklich Heimscheißer
aus einem kleinen Dorf eigentlich.
Und damit möchten wir eigentlich die Welt verändern.
Und Sallycon Valley ist ein Ort für Kreative,
wo sich Menschen wirklich kreativ zusammensetzen
und die genialsten Dinge machen,
die man sich eigentlich vorstellen kann.
Und jetzt möchte ich euch mit auf eine Reise nehmen,
wie alles angefangen hat und wo wir heute stehen.
[Musik]
Hier hat alles angefangen
und zwar im Stadtteil Wiesental in Waghäusel.
Hinter mir seht ihr die Wohnung.
Und zwar gerade die Wohnung,
wo ihr auf dem Balkon gerade diese Schüssel da seht,
das war unsere Wohnung nach unserer Hochzeit zusammen.
Hier hat Sally ihren ersten Nusszopf gebacken
und sich einfach getraut, mal was ganz anderes zu machen,
während ihrem Studium aus einem Hobby heraus
einfach den Mut zu haben,
sich eine Kamera auf einen Karton zu stellen,
um mit dem Filmen anzufangen.
So ungefähr eineinhalb Jahre später
wurde das schon ein bisschen zu klein.
Und dann sind wir einfach zu den Eltern gezogen
und zwar zu den Eltern gerade nebendran.
Das seht ihr jetzt hier vorne.
Und nebendran heißt einfach
überhalb der Schwiegereltern.
Die Wohnung war etwas größer.
Das waren die Videos aus der zweiten Küche.
Die könnt ihr heute immer noch sehen.
Und aus der zweiten Küche wurde es wieder größer.
Und dann sind wir den Stadtteil nach Kirrlach gezogen.
Und da gehen wir jetzt kurz zusammen hin,
weil da hat alles seine entscheidende Wendung genommen.
Und das würde ich euch gern zeigen.
Kommt mit.
Ja, ihr erkennt sie wieder.
Ein Originalschauplatz von Sallys Welt.
Das war die Küche Nummer drei.
Hier sind wir aus der Studenten-
– oder wir sind damals
aus der Studentenwohnungen hierhergezogen.
Die Videos wurden besser, weil wir hatten einfach mehr Licht.
Wir konnten die Lichter besser aufstellen.
Die Kameratechnik wurde besser.
Aus der 59€-Kamera wurde eine 400€-Kamera.
Und meine Frau hat hier alles alleine gemacht.
Und es ist einfach noch so ein bisschen Nostalgie.
Es ist eine wunderschöne Küche, ein Traum.
Vielleicht, wenn ich man später älter bin,
möchte ich hier wieder wohnen.
Genau in dieser Küche.
Und hier haben wir auch
unseren ersten Mitarbeiter eingestellt damals, den Frank.
Dann kam der Bahti.
Und hier wurde eigentlich Sallys Welt immer, immer größer.
Die Sally hat auch hier in dieser Wohnung
ihren Lehrerjob aufgegeben,
weil sie gemerkt hat, sie schafft es einfach nicht mehr,
alles gleichzeitig zu machen,
und ist einfach ihrem Traum gefolgt,
ihrem Hobby gefolgt, ihrer Leidenschaft gefolgt,
dem Kochen und dem Backen.
Ihr wisst ja, die Anfangsvideos waren alles Backvideos.
Dann hat sie mit Kochen angefangen.
Und dann haben viele Menschen schon gesagt:
"Hey, du hast doch immer Backvideos gebacken.
Warum
– gemacht.
Warum tust du jetzt Kochvideos machen?"
Und das ist das von der Sally.
Weil Sally denkt nicht in Schubladen.
Und es ist oftmals in Deutschland ein Problem,
dass wir in Deutschland in Schubladen denken.
Das heißt: Du bist Bäcker, fang ja nicht an zu kochen.
Du bist Schreiner, mach ja keinen Metallberuf.
Mach immer alles sicher.
Und das ist das Denken, was wir in Deutschland haben.
Und die Sally ist da ausgebrochen.
Die hat gesagt: "Wenn ich Lust auf Kochen habe,
mache ich auch Kochen.
Wenn ich als Frau Lust habe auf Bauvideos,
ist mir egal, was andere sagen,
dann mache ich halt Bauvideos,
unsere Do-it-yourself-Videos."
Und sie ist dieses Risiko eingegangen.
Sie hat nicht in Schubladen gedacht,
wie wir oftmals denken.
Und hier wohnt auch der Volkan jetzt momentan.
Also diese Küche gibt es wirklich noch.
Und wenn wir es gerade vom Schubladendenken haben.
Voll süß!
Der hat eine Pralinenschachtel drin.
Und...
Wahnsinn!
Also ich mache die Schublade auf,
da kommt eine Pralinenschachtel.
Man erwartet es nicht.
Der hat hier auch Produkt-Samples drin.
Guckt mal. Die haben wir
versucht mal zu entwerfen.
Also eine ganz krasse Geschichte, was hier drin passiert ist.
Hier waren wir vier Jahre lang,
haben unsere Tochter Samira großgezogen.
Die Ela ist hier auf die Welt gekommen.
Jetzt nicht hier, aber im Krankenhaus.
Aber das ist eine wahnsinnige, emotionale
– ihr seht es, merkt es gerade selber,
es ist wahnsinnig emotional hier drin.
Und irgendwann wurde es uns zu groß
– oder zu klein.
Das Problem war dann,
dann haben wir den Keller vom Bahti benutzt
oder halt die Souterrain-Wohnung vom Bahti.
Da waren viele Mitarbeiter,
die waren an einem ganz anderen Ort.
Und dann haben wir uns entschlossen, zu bauen,
also noch ein größeres Risiko einzugehen.
Und damals, als wir gebaut haben,
haben uns alle für verrückt gehalten.
Weil wir haben ziemlich groß gebaut,
weil wir es selber unterschätzt haben.
Und als wir groß gebaut haben,
haben wir gedacht: "Boah, das ist ja riesig!
Und da passen wir alle rein
und da können wir tolle Videos, tollen Content machen,
Content aus dem Garten, Gartenvideos."
Dann wurde Sally
– aus dem Backkanal wurde...
Also aus Sallys Tortenwelt wurde Sallys Welt
mit allem, was drumherumgehört.
Und immer, wenn Leute gesagt haben, es geht nicht,
haben wir es trotzdem gemacht.
Und ich glaube, das hat uns ausgezeichnet.
Und was wir gebaut haben,
das kennt ihr eigentlich schon,
das sind die aktuellen Videos.
Und das Wichtige war immer, den Charme nicht zu verlieren,
den Charme, nahbar zu sein,
den Charme, dass ihr das daheim
auch selber nachmachen könnt.
Vielleicht nicht in einer riesengroßen Größenordnung,
wie wir es manchmal machen, aber im Kleinen.
Das heißt, es ist auch für jeden was dabei.
Backst du gern? Baust du gern? Bastelst du gerne?
Geht es um Kindererziehung?
Geht es um alles Mögliche?
Wir haben uns nie irgendwo festlegen lassen
und in Schubladen stecken lassen.
Und das war das Wichtige.
Ja, das war dieses Kapitel.
Und jetzt geht es weiter in Sallys Welt.
Und zwar: Wir gehen nach Sallycon Valley
und schauen uns dort an, was wir dort machen.
[Musik]
Aus der Vergangenheit,
aus unserer Küche in Kirrlach
jetzt im Stadtteil Waghäusel Wiesental
seid ihr jetzt angekommen.
Vor drei Jahren haben wir das Gebäude gebaut.
[Musik]
Damals haben uns alle für verrückt
und größenwahnsinnig gehalten.
Aber dieses Gebäude wurde immer, immer kleiner.
Ja, viele neue Mitarbeiter,
viele neue Arbeitsplätze hier geschaffen.
Und was hier passiert,
das würde ich euch jetzt mal gern zeigen.
Weil das, was wir hier haben, ist viel zu klein geworden.
Und ganz wichtig bei uns:
Wenn ihr zu uns kommt,
ihr seid nicht nur geschäftlich hier,
sondern auch immer privat.
Wir wohnen hier.
Und deswegen heißt es immer, Schuhe ausziehen.
Das heißt, egal, wer hier reinkommt,
und selbst, wenn es die Bundeskanzlerin ist
oder selbst das größte Unternehmen überhaupt,
Schuhe ausziehen, Hausschuhe anziehen
und reinkommen.
Und reinkommen
– also reingekommen sind schon sehr, sehr viele Menschen.
Und zwar hier.
Ihr seht hier zum Beispiel Emilia Clarke.
Ein Roland Trettl war schon hier.
Ein Wladimir Klitschko ist bei uns
einfach im Garten gestanden mit dem Güni zusammen.
Das sind Menschen auch aus der Wirtschaft,
aus der Kultur, aus der Unterhaltung,
die uns hier in Waghäusel besuchen.
Die lustigste Geschichte war eigentlich,
als der große CEO von YouTube, Robert Kyncl,
zu uns gekommen ist.
Dann habe ich im Rathaus angerufen und habe gesagt:
"Leute, hört zu. Ein 160-Milliarden-Unternehmen
kommt uns besuchen nach Waghäusel, der Robert Kyncl.
Bitte lasst uns irgendwas machen,
irgendwie ein Blasorchester oder irgendwas.
Und was können wir da eigentlich machen?"
Da haben sie gefragt: "Murat, was sollen wir machen?"
Da sagte ich: "Keine Ahnung. Macht die Straßen sauber."
Und was ist passiert? Die sind gekommen
und haben alle Straßen hier sauber gemacht,
weil er zu uns gekommen ist.
Und Smudo von den Fantastischen Vier
war mit seiner Familie schon hier.
Also selber Menschen, die ich als Vorbilder hatte,
besuchen uns jetzt.
Und da gehen wir jetzt auch gleich weiter.
Hier, das ist die
– aus der Wall of Fame kommen wir hier
zu den ganzen Auszeichnungen,
die wir über die letzten Jahre bekommen haben.
Nicht nur die Sally, nicht nur ich,
sondern das ganze Team hier.
Hier seht ihr zum Beispiel die Goldene Kamera
mit dem Frank Elstner zusammen.
Oder Sally ist Botschafterin des Kinderhospizverbandes.
Wir haben eine eigene Stiftung,
wo wir uns für Familien und benachteiligte Kinder einsetzen.
Dann haben wir den Media Influencer Award,
den Axel Springer Award.
Das sind alles Awards.
Was mich auch stolz macht:
Wir gehören zu den zehn Topunternehmen
des Landes Baden-Württemberg.
Also Baden-Württemberg, das ist das Land von Bosch,
Mercedes, SAP, diversen Tech-Unternehmen.
Und wir gehören zu den zehn
top innovativen Jungunternehmen
und wurden, wie gesagt,
vom Landesvater Kretschmann ausgezeichnet.
Der ist übrigens bei den Grünen. Ja.
Keine Parteiwerbung jetzt hier.
Und hier liegen auch überall unsere Produkt-Samples rum.
Das heißt, Samples sind Produkte,
die noch nicht in der Produktion sind.
Und die zeige ich euch einfach.
Ich habe nichts zu verbergen.
Hier zum Beispiel,
das sind so coole Keramikschalen
oder Porzellanschalen.
Unsere Bücher.
Und ihr seht auch, es ist ein Familienunternehmen.
Das merkt man daran,
wenn man irgendwo solche Stickeralben findet von der Ela,
die sie hier irgendwie ausgefüllt hat,
und zwar "Meine Sticker-Welt für Pferde". Genau.
Es ist keine Produktplatzierung, ist von der Ela.
So. Dann gehen wir weiter.
Da seht ihr hier zum Beispiel
unsere zwei Topauszubildenden.
Genau, einmal haben wir hier die Vivi und den Max.
Und die Vivi und der Max, die machen hier eine Ausbildung
als Mediengestalter für Bild und Ton.
Vivi, was machst du eigentlich gerade?
>> VIVI: Ich tu gerade Schärfe ziehen und Ton machen.
>> MURAT: Also sie macht gerade den Ton.
Genau. Okay, super.
Und der Max, der kommt aus Herzogenaurach.
Das sind ungefähr 260, 290 Kilometer bis hierher, richtig?
>> MAX: Ja, so um den Dreh.
>> MURAT: Genau. Und diese zwei Jugendlichen,
heranwerdende Erwachsenen
machen bei uns ihre Ausbildung
und lernen von uns natürlich von den Besten.
Weil es ist nicht einfach, in Waghäusel Fachkräfte zu finden.
Also tun wir unsere Fachkräfte selber hochziehen.
Und ihr werdet euer Leben lang bei uns bleiben.
Habe ich recht, ihr zwei?
>> VIVI & MAX: Ja.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Wir werden ihnen nicht nur
die ganzen technischen Dinge vermitteln
oder was zu einer Ausbildung gehört,
sondern auch familiäre Werte.
Genau.
Könnte ich dein Papa sein?
Nein, oder?
>> MAX: Das könnte ein bisschen schwer werden.
>> MURAT: Ja, das könnte ein bisschen schwer werden.
Genau, könnte ein bisschen schwer werden,
aber trotzdem,
unsere Mitarbeiter, unsere Auszubildenden
sind wie unsere eigenen Kinder, unsere eigenen Freunde.
Und wie gesagt...
Was machst du eigentlich gerade?
Du schneidest gerade was?
>> MAX: Ich schneide. Ja, genau.
Und ich bereite noch was vor für das Video morgen.
>> MURAT: Ah, okay.
So. Dann gehen wir weiter.
Aus der etwas kleineren Küche in Kirrlach,
wie gesagt, hier in Wiesental jetzt, Stadtteil Waghäusel.
So. Und hier in der Küche entsteht alles.
Diese Küche haben wir gebaut.
Wir sagen zwar Showküche hier dazu,
es ist aber keine Showküche,
weil wir machen wirklich alles echt hier.
Hier ist auch wirklich echt das Ganze hier.
Hier.
Ja, ist echt.
So. Hier ist nichts Plastik, hier ist alles echt.
Und hier kochen wir auch für uns,
für das ganze Team zusammen.
Und hier haben wir den Siamak.
Siamak ist Mediengestalter für Bild und Ton?
>> SIAMAK: Digital und Print.
>> MURAT: Ah, Digital und Print. Genau.
Und der Siamak
– du bist wie lange hier? Drei, vier Jahre jetzt schon?
>> SIAMAK: Drei, dreieinhalb sogar.
>> MURAT: Dreieinhalb Jahre?
So. Dreieinhalb Jahre keine Lohnerhöhung
und der Siamak ist immer noch hier.
So.
Auf jeden Fall das Coole an dem ganzen Ding ist:
Siamak kommt aus einem ganz anderen Bereich,
nicht aus der Produktentwicklung.
Und er sieht Dinge mit anderen Augen.
Das heißt, dieser Spruch:
"Haben wir schon immer so gemacht,
machen wir immer so weiter",
das zieht beim Siamak nicht, weil er alles neu macht.
Und er sieht alles aus einem anderen Blickwinkel.
Und das kostet uns manchmal auch ein bisschen Geld.
Habe ich recht?
>> SIAMAK: Lehrgeld, ja.
>> MURAT: Ja, Lehrgeld.
>> SIAMAK: Teures Lehrgeld.
>> MURAT: Hier mal ein cooles Beispiel:
Wir entwickeln ja Dinge aus der völligen Naivität.
Meine Frau möchte etwas haben,
sie sagt uns, was sie haben möchte,
und wir versuchen, es zu verwirklichen.
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> MURAT: Wir bringen es erst auf Papier.
Nachdem wir es auf Papier gebracht haben,
schicken wir es zu einem Hersteller,
der es für uns produzieren soll.
Und eigentlich wollten wir mal eine Simply-Serie,
eine Topfserie machen.
Und da hat der Hersteller zu uns gesagt:
"Das ist gar nicht möglich. Vergiss das."
Und wenn einer das zu uns sagt,
dann werden wir erst richtig wuschig
und sagen: "Wir möchten es trotzdem machen."
Und hier war das Problem einfach
– wir haben es jetzt trotzdem machen lassen.
Das ist ein Hand Sample, also mit Hand gemacht.
Und das Ding kostet 3.500 €,
diese Idee zu verwirklichen.
>> SIAMAK: Teuerster Topf der Welt, glaube ich.
>> MURAT: Ja, wirklich. Ohne Spaß.
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> MURAT: So. Und dann haben wir den Topf machen lassen,
obwohl der Hersteller gesagt hat, es geht nicht.
Wir haben es trotzdem gemacht.
Jetzt hat sich rausgestellt: Wenn hier Wasser aufkocht,
dann kommt das Wasser ja,
das geht an der schwächsten Stelle raus
und läuft
– das Wasser läuft dann außen am Tropf herunter.
War natürlich wirklich
mies.
So.
>> SIAMAK: Aber wir haben es probiert.
>> MURAT: Wir haben es probiert. Genau.
Auch wenn es...
Es war ja nicht dein Geld.
So. Es war ja mein Geld
– oder auch nicht von mir, das von meiner Frau.
Auf jeden Fall, kann mal passieren, solche Dinge.
Und hier stellen wir natürlich auch geniale Sachen her.
Sachen, die uns eigentlich gar keiner zumutet.
Wirklich. Von coolen Töpfen
– da war es ja auch so.
Da hat auch einer gesagt, es geht nicht.
Und wir haben gesagt: "Mach es trotzdem."
>> SIAMAK: Und es ging.
>> MURAT: Und es ging. Genau.
Dann haben wir natürlich auch
– das Neueste, was wir machen: Besteck, was wir machen,
die eigenen Designs.
Nicht nur das Besteck an sich, die Designs,
sondern auch das ganze Packaging
wird alles aus unserem Team heraus gemacht.
Wir geben nichts nach draußen, weil wir nicht
– nicht, weil wir geizig sind, sondern wir möchten,
dass die Menschen, die das entwickeln,
auch genau das spüren, was wir hier drin spüren.
Spürst du es, Siamak?
>> SIAMAK: Ich spüre es voll.
>> MURAT: Oh, Wahnsinn!
So. Er spürt es.
Bist du eigentlich glücklich hier, muss man ehrlich sagen?
>> SIAMAK: Ja, doch.
Ich laufe doch immer mit einem Grinsen rum.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SIAMAK: Ich glaube, du hast mich noch nie
schlecht gelaunt gesehen.
>> MURAT: Nee, aber ohne Spaß.
>> SIAMAK: Ja.
>> MURAT: Was sind deine Drogen, Siamak?
So.
Also, auch wenn die Kamera aus wäre,
wärst du trotzdem glücklicher hier?
>> SIAMAK: Ja.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Und früher war es einfach so:
Ein Trend ist in Amerika oder irgendwo entstanden
und bis der Trend hier war,
hat es drei bis vier oder fünf Jahre gedauert.
Heute entstehen Trends irgendwo auf der Welt
und durch Social Media sind sie auch sofort hier.
Das heißt, man muss schnell sein,
wenig Strukturen haben.
Das heißt, wenn ein großes Unternehmen
ein Produkt rausbringen möchte,
dauert es zwei bis drei Jahre.
Wir schaffen es von der Idee bis zum Produkt
– sechs Monate schaffen wir, oder?
>> SIAMAK: Ja.
Manchmal zwei Monate, manchmal drei, manchmal sechs.
>> MURAT: So ist es.
Aber wir haben auch schon zwei Jahre gehabt,
beim Ausrollstab.
>> SIAMAK: Richtig.
>> MURAT: Da ging ein bisschen was in die Hose.
Aber jetzt haben wir es hingekriegt.
Und das ist heutzutage der ganze Trick:
Nicht mehr der größte Fisch frisst alles,
sondern der schnellste Fisch.
Und deswegen sind wir schnell,
weil alles im Haus passiert und mit unserem eigenen Team.
>> SIAMAK: Auf direktem Wege.
>> MURAT: Genau.
So. Das ist das Geheimnis:
Keine Strukturen, keine Hierarchien.
Du kannst zu mir sagen, was du willst.
Du kannst mich auch beleidigen.
Keine Hierarchien. Genau.
>> SIAMAK: Das macht der Güni für uns.
>> MURAT: Ja, das macht der Güni für euch. Genau.
>> GÜNTER: So richtig.
>> KAMERAMANN: Ja, was hast du denn da vorher druntergemacht?
>> GÜNTER: Kleber. Kleber.
>> KAMERAMANN: Kleber?
>> GÜNTER: Kleber.
Und dann muss man sie anklopfen so.
Und ich habe mir ja da was ausgedacht.
Ich habe mir da eine Hilfe gebaut,
eine Hilfe gebastelt
zum Anklopfen.
Dann wird es nämlich noch besser.
>> KAMERAMANN: Das hält.
>> MURAT: So.
Was heißt das? Schnell heißt auch:
Hier entsteht etwas, die Sally hat was gekocht
und es wird sofort fotografiert,
sofort digitalisiert
und dann geht es sofort raus in die Welt.
Und wer das macht, das zeige ich euch jetzt.
Da würden wir nämlich gern
mal zum Josh und zur Sarah gehen.
[Musik]
Herzlich willkommen bei den Agenten Ripplinger und Palik
und zwar bei Sarah und Josh.
Sarah und Josh machen bei uns im Kreativbereich
die Fotos und die ganze Kameratechnik.
Hier haben wir zum Beispiel Frau Palik.
So. Frau Palik macht hier die ganzen Fotos.
Ich habe euch gesagt, man muss heutzutage schnell sein,
wenig Strukturen haben.
Die entstehen von alleine.
Schnell sein, das heißt,
dort drüben wird gekocht, wird gebacken
und hier wird es sofort fotografiert.
Sarah, machst du das
– hast du das extra wegen dem Dreh gemacht
oder machst du wirklich gerade was?
>> SARAH: Nee, nur wegen dem Dreh.
>> MURAT: Aha.
>> SARAH: Ich arbeite doch sonst nichts.
>> MURAT: Ach so. Sie gibt es wenigstens zu.
So. Auf jeden Fall
– und das ist wichtig, kreative Menschen hier drin zu haben.
Weil, was auch dazugehört,
ist, diese Menschen fair zu bezahlen.
Was
– ich bezahle euch doch fair, oder?
>> SARAH: Murat, du stehst im Bild.
>> MURAT: Ah, Entschuldigung. Ja.
Nicht im Bild stehen.
Genau.
Und zwar: Das ist der Grund, warum ich sage,
nicht mit Freelancern.
Und zwar: Freelancer sind ja Selbständige.
Wenn ich jetzt einen Auftrag,
wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel solche Fotos machen müsste
und ich müsste eine Agentur beauftragen,
würde das viel zu lange dauern.
Dann würden die meistens irgendjemanden schicken,
der uns gar nicht kennt und gar nicht das fühlt, was wir...
>> FRAU AUS DEM OFF: Es hat eine Firma Selz geklingelt.
>> MURAT: Ja, es hat geklingelt.
So. Auf jeden Fall,
der würde das gar nicht fühlen, was wir fühlen,
und nicht wissen, wie sich die Sally bewegt
und allem Drum und Dran.
Das heißt, kreative Menschen möchte ich bei uns behalten
und die müssen immer da sein.
Es kann auch mal sein, dass die Sarah mal
vielleicht mal nichts zu tun hat.
Kann ja auch mal sein, oder nicht?
Ja. So.
Dann tut sie uns halt beim Kochen helfen oder sie hilft da.
Genauso beim Josh.
Mit dem Josh bauen wir dann einfach was im Garten.
Also es ist auch wichtig,
dass jemand nicht immer nur das macht, was er gelernt hat,
sondern auch in verschiedene Bereiche reingeht.
Und wie gesagt,
hier werden gerade die ganzen Fotos gemacht.
Und hier im Hintergrund das ist unser Plan
und zwar unser Plan zur Weltherrschaft.
Und irgendwann, wenn alles in Schutt und Asche liegt,
in 300 Jahren werden Archäologen diesen Plan ausgraben
und sagen: "Boah! Was?! Die wollten die Weltherrschaft.
Die wollten die Welt erobern mit diesem Plan."
Also eine geniale Geschichte.
So. Und jetzt gehen wir mal ganz kurz zum Josh.
Und Josh sitzt da.
Nee.
>> JOSH: Ich bin hier!
>> MURAT: Ja, der Josh ist hinter der Kamera.
Aber jetzt: So sieht der Josh vor der Kamera aus.
Da gehen wir jetzt mal hin.
So. Gerade noch hinter der Kamera
und jetzt vor der Kamera, der Josh.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und der Josh schneidet eigentlich gerade
den Film, den ihr gerade anschaut.
>> JOSH: Inception.
>> MURAT: Inception heißt das.
Also das ist wirklich
– er springt in der Matrix hin und her
und schneidet gerade das Video, was ihr gerade anschaut.
Und da, wo wir...
>> JOSH: Und hier ist der Beweis.
Ihr seht es im Video.
>> MURAT: Kannst du mich eigentlich schlanker machen?
Ist das möglich oder geht das nur bei Bild?
>> JOSH: Das geht nur bei Bild.
>> MURAT: Oh!
Okay.
Ich weiß, ich muss ein bisschen abnehmen.
Ich bin auch schon dabei.
Auf jeden Fall, hier wird alles geschnitten.
Hast du gerade gelacht, Sarah?
>> SARAH: Nee.
>> MURAT: So. Hier wird gerade alles geschnitten
mit allem Drum und Dran.
Das, was ihr hier seht, die zwei Räume,
das waren mal früher Büros.
Aber, weil wir so gewachsen sind
und weil wir das einfach gebraucht haben,
ist das jetzt ein Fotostudio
und hier werden die ganzen Videos gecutet.
Mein Gott! Mach mich doch ein bisschen schlanker.
Du kannst das auch
– findest du nicht, dass, wenn du das Ding
schwarz-weiß machst, dass ich schlanker wirke?
>> JOSH: Wir...
Wir können das mal ausprobieren. Warte kurz hier.
>> SARAH: Das ist ein Mythos.
>> MURAT: Und zwar Sarah macht gerade
– die ganzen Bilder, die sie jetzt gerade geschossen hat,
hat sie schon auf dem Bildschirm.
Und von hier aus, also das heißt aus diesem Kreativbereich,
wird jetzt alles nach oben geschickt.
Und oben wird das sozusagen feinpoliert und feingeschliffen.
Und die obere Ge-
– das obere Gebäude war eigentlich geplant
für die Wohnung der Schwiegereltern.
Aber wir sind so gewachsen, da haben die Schwiegereltern
wirklich nur einen Tag drin gewohnt.
Und wie gesagt, ich sage immer,
ohne die Schwiegereltern wäre das alles hier nicht möglich.
Die haben dann eingesehen,
die haben einfach keinen Platz mehr.
Die haben dann gesagt: "Murat, hör zu.
Dann ziehen wir halt erst später ein
und wenn ihr mit Sallycon Valley,
drüben mit dem Bau fertig seid."
Und solange wird das alles missbraucht
für unsere Taten hier
rund um Sallycon Valley und Sallys Welt.
Mein Gott! Noch mal Sally, das geht ja gar nicht.
So. Jetzt geht es weiter.
Jetzt gucken wir, was oben los ist.
Und da stelle ich euch mal das andere Team vor.
>> JOSH: Warte auf mich! Ich muss doch drehen.
>> MURAT: Ja, genau. Ach so, stimmt.
Nimm die Kamera.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> MURAT: Genau. So.
Ja, jetzt sind wir oben in den Büros.
Und ihr wisst ja, kennt die Büros eigentlich schon.
Weil hier haben mal ursprünglich
die Schwiegereltern gewohnt für einen Tag.
Wir sind aber so sehr gewachsen,
dass sie gesagt haben: "Okay, wir ziehen mal jetzt kurz aus,
dass ihr weiterhin wachsen könnt."
Und ich würde euch mal gern
die anderen Teammitglieder mal vorstellen.
Kommt einfach mal mit.
[Musik]
So. Jetzt sind wir in der Produktentwicklung.
Tut mir leid, dass es hier so aussieht.
Die sind einfach durchgeknallt hier,
der Siamak
– der Volkan ist heute gar nicht da.
Und hier werden die ganzen Produkte entwickelt,
die 3D-Muster gemacht.
Und ihr seht, hier ist alles zugestellt.
Woah!
Wo kommt das her?!
Wahnsinn! Das muss ich haben!
Das ist übrigens das neue Murat Knife.
Wahnsinn!
Und hier sind auch solche Sachen
wie hier diese Toffifee-Verpackung.
Auf über 11 Millionen Toffifee-Verpackungen
wurde unser Logo abgedruckt.
Das war ein Gewinnspiel, war letztes Jahr.
Eine geniale Geschichte!
Ja. Dann gehen wir weiter.
Da hinten sind nämlich noch der Bahti und der Dennis.
[Musik]
So.
Ja, hier sind wir beim Bahti und beim Dennis im Büro.
Der Bahti macht die ganze Lohnbuchhaltung
und das ganze Personalmanagement,
alles, was mit Zahlen zu tun hat,
wovon ich gar keine Ahnung habe.
Bahti, isch Lohn da?
>> BAHTIYAR: Natürlich! Waghäusel isch stabil.
>> MURAT: Ja, Waghäusel isch stabil.
Dennis ist nicht da. Warum? Wo ist Dennis?
>> BAHTIYAR: Die Krücken suchen? Keine Ahnung.
>> MURAT: Ja, irgendwas ist..
>> BAHTIYAR: Oder einen Rucksack?
Der hat seinen Rucksack verloren.
>> MURAT: Der ist crank. Genau.
Hier ist eigentlich Personal, Marketing und
– keine Ahnung, was sie hier machen.
Ich gehe mal weiter und zeig euch mal die anderen Leute.
[Musik]
Wahnsinn!
Lohn isch da.
Lohn isch da und zwar auch für die Leute hier.
Das sind die Nerds hier.
Herzlich willkommen bei den Nerds!
Und diese Nerds haben auch Superkräfte.
Und die bedienen die ganzen Felder
Instagram, Pinterest,
Facebook, YouTube mit allem Drum und Dran.
Und zwar das, was unten produziert wird,
wird hier drin verarbeitet und geht dann weiter.
Verarbeitet wird es natürlich
hier von der Lena zum Beispiel.
Und die Lena
– Lena, was machst du noch mal hier?
>> LENA: Ich mache mein Praxissemester.
>> MURAT: Ah, sie macht ein Praxissemester
und eigentlich studiert sie.
Und zwar studiert sie wo?
>> LENA: An der Hochschule in Mannheim
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> LENA: Kommunikationsdesign.
Und später wird sie dann auch hier landen.
Wie alle.
Alle werden irgendwann hier landen.
Landen
– gelandet hier ist auch hier der Ben zum Beispiel.
Ben, von wo bist du gelandet?
>> BEN: Von Bruchsal.
>> MURAT: Von Bruchsal.
>> BEN: Ja, ich bin nicht so weit hergekommen.
Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Also Bruchsal und Pforzheim machen immer
so ein Kopf-an-Kopf Rennen:
Wer ist die hässlichste Stadt Deutschlands?
Ja, das ist dann auch so.
>> BEN: Ja.
>> MURAT: So.
Dann haben wir hier
die Aline.
Und die Aline, die macht die ganzen Bilder,
die ganzen Bearbeitungen für Pinterest, die ganzen
– da gibt es ganz, ganz viele Sachen mit Computern,
die verstehe ich einfach nicht.
Muss ich auch nicht verstehen,
weil hier ist zum Beispiel wieder der Max.
Der Max ist eigentlich überall.
Gibt es dich eigentlich zweimal?
Weil er schneidet hier auch weiter die ganzen Videos.
Dann ist da die Vivi.
Die Vivi ist hier auch wieder am Ton.
So. Dann gehen wir weiter.
Und hier entstehen auch die Ideen.
Hier hocken wir zusammen, hier kochen wir zusammen,
hier reden wir zusammen
und hier entstehen auch die Idee
– oder entstand die Idee für Restberry Garden.
Und ein bisschen der Kopf von Restberry Garden
ist hier der Josh.
So.
Ja. Und das ist der Josh.
Und der Josh, du bist eigentlich...
Josh ist...
Du bist wirklich Produktdesigner.
>> JOSH: Richtig.
>> MURAT: Richtig.
>> JOSH: Ich studiere.
>> MURAT: Studierter Produktdesigner.
Also kein gefakter wie der Siamak.
Und zwar: Er macht wirklich Produktdesign.
Und er ist aber auch noch im Studium.
Er macht gerade seinen Master und zwar in Karlsruhe.
>> JOSH: In Pforzheim.
>> MURAT: Auch in Pforzheim?
Mein Gott! Was machen die Pforzheimer hier?!
Aber du kommst ursprünglich nicht aus Pforzheim, gell?
>> JOSH: Vom Bodensee.
>> MURAT: Vom Bodensee.
Also würdest du bestätigen,
dass Pforzheim die hässlichste Stadt neben Bruchsal ist?
>> JOSH: Neben Bruchsal, ja.
>> MURAT: Ja? Okay.
Alles okay, super.
So.
Das ist das Wohnzimmer der Schwiegereltern.
Und da hinten ist die Küche.
Der Siamak ist im Schlafzimmer von den Schwiegereltern.
Der Bahti ist im Gästezimmer.
Hier ist alles gewachsen.
Und das ist auch der Grund,
warum wir demnächst umziehen werden.
Bevor wir aber umziehen,
müssen wir noch ein bisschen in die Vergangenheit,
also "Zurück in die Zukunft"-mäßig,
wie es eigentlich online mit dem Onlineshop angefangen hat.
Das war ungefähr vor sieben Jahren,
am 15. November 2013,
also wird unser Shop sieben Jahre alt.
Den haben wir damals mit dem Saban gemacht,
weil sich der Saban mit Computern auskennt.
Er ist nicht der Hellste, genauso wie ich,
aber das hat er hinbekommen.
Und da fahren wir jetzt hin und schauen uns das mal alles an.
[Musik]
So. Nicht nur dieses Auto ist Geschichte,
sondern auch die Geschichte, die ich euch jetzt erzähle.
Und zwar sind wir hier gerade in Oberndorf am Neckar.
Und hier hat alles angefangen und zwar mit dem Sallys Shop.
[Musik]
Mach auf!
>> SABAN: Ja. Hi!
[Musik]
>> MURAT: Saban, ich komme jetzt rein, okay?
>> SABAN: Ja, okay, Murat.
>> MURAT: Tu wenigstens so,
als würdest du dich freuen, mich zu sehen. Bitte!
>> SABAN: Ja. Ja, mache ich.
>> MURAT: Lach nicht
– lach, meine ich.
Okay?
>> SABAN: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SABAN: Hi, Murat!
>> MURAT: Hi!
Hör auf mich zu begrüßen.
>> SABAN: Hi, Murat!
>> MURAT: Wir kennen uns doch schon.
So. Wir sind hier bei uns im Shop,
Sallys-Welt-Shop.
Und zwar
– wann hat es angefangen, Saban?
Am 15. November 2013
>> SABAN: Genau.
>> MURAT: wurden hier die Grundpfeiler
für Sallys Shop gemacht.
>> SABAN: Ja.
>> MURAT: Genau. Das ist Saban.
Mit dem bin ich übrigens aufgewachsen,
von Kindesbeinen schon aufgewachsen.
Du kennst mich.
>> SABAN: Ja, klar.
>> MURAT: Ich kenne dich.
Ja.
>> SABAN: Das reicht auch.
>> MURAT: Das reicht auch schon.
Mehr brauchen wir nicht erzählen.
>> SABAN: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und wie gesagt, wir sind beim Saban
in seinem privaten Haus.
Und hier in diesen
– wie viele Quadratmeter sind das ungefähr, Saban?
Sechs Quadratmeter
>> SABAN: Sechs.
>> MURAT: mit Dachschräge.
>> SABAN: Ja, mit Dachschräge 6,5 Quadratmeter.
>> MURAT: Und das Lustige war ja:
Ich habe damals bei Sallys Geburtstag Saban angesprochen:
– jetzt weiß ich, es war Sallys Geburtstag –
"Können wir nicht einen Koch- und einen Backshop eröffnen?"
Und er sagt dann zu mir
– ich kann mich noch an einen Spruch erinnern:
"Du Idiot, was hast du mit Kochen und Backen zu tun?"
>> SABAN: Genau.
>> MURAT: Ich habe ihm dann die Geschichte mit Sally
erzählt, mit ihrem YouTube-Kanal.
Und er hat dann gesagt, okay, er macht das,
er investiert aber nicht, er sagt es mir gleich,
er hat selber keine Kohle.
>> SABAN: Genau.
Ja, so war es.
>> MURAT: Und so war es auch.
Und so haben wir eigentlich angefangen.
In diesen Räumlichkeiten hier
waren wir ein Jahr lang wirklich drin.
>> SABAN: Hm.
>> MURAT: Und das ist der Grundpfeiler von unserem Shop.
>> SABAN: Ja. Ja, so ist das.
>> MURAT: Saban, erzähl mal uns
von deinem krassen Logistikzentrum, wie du hier drin
in diesen sechs Quadratmetern alles gegründet hast.
>> SABAN: Wir haben einfach angefangen.
Das ist halt Fakt.
Wir haben einfach hier dann...
Hier waren unsere
– ihre Fondants,
praktisch unsere Food-Abteilung.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SABAN: Hier war mein...
>> MURAT: Also hier war komplett die Food-Abteilung?
>> SABAN: Hier war die Food-Abteilung. Genau.
Aber, ja...
>> MURAT: Wo war das Rechenzentrum?
>> SABAN: Das Rechenzentrum war hier.
>> MURAT: Hier war ein Rechenzentrum?
>> SABAN: Genau.
>> MURAT: Also hier war
>> MURAT: hier ein großes Rechenzentrum.
Wo war eigentlich die Non-Food-Abteilung, Saban?
>> SABAN: Die Non-Food-Abteilung war hier.
>> MURAT: Was war da?
Hier der Schrank, war der immer schon drin.
>> SABAN: Nee, der Schrank war schon nicht da.
Aber wir hatten da ein Regal
und da waren dann unsere Non-Food-Artikel drin.
Die haben wir dann da schön sortiert
und haben da praktisch dann immer
– also gleich hinter mir konnte ich immer überall alles.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SABAN: Kurze Strecken, kurze Wege.
>> MURAT: Also ihr seht, es gibt zwar den Spruch:
"Alles fängt im Kleinen an",
aber der Saban hat es übertreiben müssen.
>> SABAN: Ja.
Wie in der Natur.
>> MURAT: Genau. Und sein Sohn, der Mikail,
der musste dann zu euch ins Schlafzimmer.
>> SABAN: Genau.
Wir haben den Mikail dann einfach verfrachtet.
Der musste dann einfach zu uns,
weil wir gesagt haben: "So. Und wir brauchen den Platz hier."
Und der hat dann einfach stillschweigend gesagt:
>> MURAT: Kann passieren. Mit zwei Jahren...
>> SABAN: "Es kommt gleich Fußball. Alles okay."
>> MURAT: Mit zwei Jahren kann er sich auch nicht wehren.
>> SABAN: Ja, stimmt.
>> MURAT: Genau. Und so hat es angefangen,
wie gesagt, im Kleinen.
Eine gigantische Geschichte,
aus einem Kinderzimmer heraus
ein Unternehmen aufgebaut
>> SABAN: Ja.
>> MURAT: mit dir zusammen.
>> SABAN & MURAT: Ja.
>> MURAT: So. Das Lustige ist auch:
Wir haben dieses Haus hier zusammen renoviert.
>> SABAN: Genau.
>> MURAT: Kannst du bitte jetzt
gerade in die Kamera noch sagen,
dass ich ein guter Handwerker bin?
>> SABAN: Also der Murat ist der beste Handwerker,
den man sich wünschen kann.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SABAN: So...
Ja, das ist richtig, nicht?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SABAN: Schneide es nicht raus, Josh.
Lass es drin.
Ja.
>> MURAT: Genau. Und jetzt, wie gesagt,
sind wir von
– aus Oberndorf am Neckar gehen wir jetzt nach Sulz
und sehen jetzt, was wir da wieder...
Da sind wir auch wieder masochistisch veranlagt gewesen.
>> SABAN: Genau. Da haben wir auch eine Baustelle jetzt.
>> MURAT: Da haben wir jetzt auch eine Riesenbaustelle.
Und da entsteht jetzt gerade das neue Logistikzentrum.
Und dort gehen wir hin.
>> SABAN: Ja.
>> MURAT: Okay.
Aber jetzt zeigen wir noch ganz kurz
ein paar Sachen aus dem Haus.
>> SABAN: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ganz, ganz lustige Sachen.
Gehen wir kurz runter?
>> SABAN: Ja, >> MURAT: Okay.
>> SABAN: machen wir.
>> MURAT: Dann zeige ich euch nämlich
das kleinste Klo der Welt.
>> SABAN: Aber weißt du,
warum ich das kleinste Klo der Welt gebaut habe?
Weil ich habe ja auch kleine Freunde
und jedes Mal, wenn mein kleiner Freund zu Besuch kommt,
dann habe ich gesagt, damit er sich heimisch fühlt.
>> MURAT: So.
>> SABAN: Ja. Na?
>> MURAT: Kannst du das rausschneiden, Josh?
Komm, zeigen wir kurz das Haus.
So.
Du läufst jetzt gerade die Treppen runter
und dann ist hier das Klo.
Warte kurz.
Und zwar
– aua!
Aua!
Und dann musst du hier rein.
Und guck mal, das ist das kleinste Klo der Welt.
Und ich bin ja nicht der Größte.
Aber ich glaube, wenn der Josh jetzt hier drin wäre,
dann könnte der sich nicht mal
– wie willst du dir denn hier deinen Arsch wischen?!
Kannst du mir das mal sagen?
So.
Dieses Gebäude hier
– jetzt ohne Spaß. Das ist jetzt das alte Haus vom Saban.
Das haben wir komplett restauriert, gell?
>> SABAN: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und das Problem ist einfach bei so alten Häusern:
Hier ist immer alles ein bisschen krumm und schepp.
Und dann muss man es halt machen, so, dass es passt.
Wenn ich gerade hier diese Fugen hier sehe,
sag mal: Haben die sich
– was sind denn das für Fugen, Saban?
Der Hammer!
Es ging aber nicht anders.
Weil der Boden ist nicht so eben.
Guck mal. Ich stehe hier gerade im Loch.
>> SABAN: Der Boden war nicht eben.
Jetzt muss man aber auch hier sagen:
Hier war ja auch ursprünglich ein
– hier war ja mal ein Bad.
Das haben wir doch abgerissen.
>> MURAT: Ah, stimmt! Hier war ein Bad.
Ja. Da ist ja mein Schwiegervater dann reingekommen.
Dann haben wir ihn noch gefragt:
"Hey, kann man die Wand"
– wir haben ja gedacht, das ist eine Trägerwand, damals.
Aber Murat hat gesagt: "Das kannst du wegschlagen."
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SABAN: Und dann habe ich gesagt: "Moment.
Ich rufe erst meinen Schwiegervater."
Dann haben wir den Opa gerufen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SABAN: Und der hat dann nachher gesagt:
"Hau sie weg." Weil die...
>> MURAT: Dann haben wir eine Trägerwand rausgerissen.
>> SABAN: Ja.
>> MURAT: Aber dürfen wir das jetzt öffentlich sagen?
Weil nicht, dass du jetzt vom Bauamt...
>> SABAN: Nee, das ist keine.
Also wir durften, das ist keine Träger-
– also die Trägerwand war hier,
aber die haben wir ja oben dann eingefasst Murat.
Also die haben wir auch rausgehauen übrigens,
die Wand hier.
>> MURAT: O mein Gott! Was ist denn das?!
Du hast eine Waffe im Haus!
Ist das eine echte?
Saban,
da.
Super.
So. Der hat...
Jetzt weiß ich auch
– ihr wisst ja auch, Saban hat ja immer
gern mal Süßen Schnee im Shop verkauft.
Jetzt wisst ihr auch, was das ist.
>> SABAN: Die Nachbarn dürfen das nicht sehen.
Sonst...
>> MURAT: So.
Keine Angst. Wir sind hier in Oberndorf am Neckar.
Hier hat jeder einen Schuss.
Ja, Saban auch.
Ja.
So.
Es ist keine echte Waffe gewesen.
Macht das zu Hause bitte nicht nach.
Auf jeden Fall eine geniale Geschichte,
was wir zusammen erlebt haben.
>> SABAN: Ja.
>> MURAT: Wirklich.
>> SABAN: Echt viel erlebt, Murat.
>> MURAT: So. Soll ich dich jetzt umarmen?
>> SABAN: Ja, komm, Murat.
>> MURAT: Nein, nein, nein!
Du hast doch bestimmt Milben.
Der hat bestimmt Milben. Doch.
So. Und jetzt von hier aus
gehen wir jetzt, wie gesagt, nach
>> MURAT & SABAN: Sulz.
>> MURAT: Und in Sulz
werdet ihr eine gigantische Überraschung erleben.
Ja.
Komm mit.
>> SABAN: Gehen wir.
>> MURAT: Geiler Typ.
[Musik]
Aus dem Kinderzimmer,
aus Oberndorf am Neckar nach Sulz am Neckar.
Das sind vielleicht gerade mal 10 km.
Und das ist jetzt unser großer Teich.
Und hier können wir uns verwirklichen.
In den letzten Jahren sind wir wirklich jedes Jahr umgezogen,
in den letzten sechs Jahren.
Es wurde immer größer und immer größer.
Und dieses Jahr
Mitte des Jahres haben wir das Glück gehabt,
eine Halle zu erwerben,
die früher ehemals eine metallverarbeitende Fabrik war.
Das ist eine riesengroße Lagerhalle
auf einem Grundstück mit 66.000 Quadratmetern.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie viele Fußballfelder das sind,
aber sehr, sehr viele Fußballfelder.
Und hier können wir wachsen.
Und hier investieren wir natürlich
auch in unser Logistikzentrum.
Wir werden alles komplett modernisieren.
Wir werden oben auf dem Dach Photovoltaik machen.
Wir werden die Fassade auch modernisieren,
energetisch sanieren
und wir werden hier wachsen können,
die nächsten Jahre hoffentlich doch.
Den Platz haben wir jetzt.
Und wie es innen drin aussieht?
Da gehen wir jetzt mal kurz rein.
[Musik]
In dieser Halle wurde über Jahrzehnte Metall verarbeitet.
Diese Arbeitsstätte hat vor Kurzem zugemacht.
Viele Menschen haben ihre Arbeitsplätze verloren.
Und wir haben das jetzt hier übernommen
und werden hier unser neues Logistikzentrum bauen.
Große Hochregallager
und Platz für mindestens 20.000 Paletten.
Und es ist so eine krasse Geschichte:
aus dem Kinderzimmer
– aus der Küche ins Kinderzimmer,
vom Kinderzimmer in so eine große Halle.
Hier werden wir natürlich noch alles optimieren,
die ganzen
– wir sind gerade momentan in den Anfängen.
Das wird jetzt noch
– zwei, drei Jahre wird es noch dauern,
bis wir alles optimiert haben,
bis wir die ganze Halle gemacht haben.
Und Sallys Welt kann hier weiterhin wachsen
und, wie gesagt, viele, viele tolle neue Arbeitsplätze,
Ausbildungsstellen schaffen.
[Musik]
Ich wollte schon immer mal
in meinem eigenen Laden einkaufen.
[Musik]
So. Jetzt waren wir online.
Und jetzt sind wir stationär
und zwar in Mannheim im Q 6 Q 7.
Das ist ein Einkaufszentrum in Mannheim,
25 Minuten von uns, von Waghäusel entfernt.
Und da haben wir das Abenteuer gewagt
und wirklich noch zu einer
– zur jetzigen Zeit einen stationären Laden aufzumachen,
den ersten Sally Flagship Store
im Q 6 Q 7 Mannheim.
So.
Vor ungefähr drei bis vier Monaten
haben wir eigentlich schon angefangen,
diesen Shop hier mal aufzubauen,
wo wir noch gar nicht wussten, dass wir eigentlich
einen Shop in Mannheim aufbauen werden.
Und zwar haben wir einfach ein paar Materialien ausprobiert,
wir haben einfach ein paar Ideen gesammelt.
Ja. Dabei wussten wir eigentlich gar nicht,
was wir richtig machen, gell?
>> ALEX: Ja.
>> MURAT: Nur mal Dinge ausprobieren.
>> ALEX: Einfach drauf los.
>> MURAT: Der Alex hat hier zum Beispiel
– vom Mannheimer Hafen hat er hier uns alte Bretter besorgt.
Diese alten Bretter, die haben wir dann
abgeschliffen und bearbeitet.
Dann haben wir hier
diese Platten besorgt
und die haben wir künstlich rosten lassen.
Ja, künstlich war es, Alex. Genau.
>> ALEX: Ja.
>> MURAT: Die haben wir rosten lassen, diese Lochbleche.
Und so haben wir einfach ein paar Sachen ausprobiert,
um später, wenn wir mal
irgendwann einen Shop bauen sollten,
– so war der Gedanke –
dass wir ungefähr wissen, wie es aussieht.
Ja.
Und jetzt werden wir diesen Shop wieder abbauen
nach drei Monaten, vier Monaten Standzeit.
Und mal schauen, wo wir es jetzt wieder aufbauen, oder?
Und, wie gesagt, man probiert einfach Dinge aus,
weiß noch
– und das ist halt der Vorteil an uns,
dass wir einfach Dinge vor der Garage ausprobieren können.
Ihr wisst, es gibt viele Unternehmen,
die sind groß geworden in der Garage.
Und vielleicht werden wir groß
vor der Garage. Habe ich recht?
>> MURAT & ALEX: Genau.
>> MURAT: Zu einer Zeit, wo immer mehr Läden schließen,
wo die Innenstädte immer mehr gleich aussehen,
weil immer die gleichen Läden eröffnen,
haben wir dieses Ding gewagt.
Weil wir waren nie die Menschen,
die die einfachen Dinge machen möchten.
Weil die einfachen Dinge, die macht jeder.
Also haben wir uns auf den Weg gemacht, auf die Reise,
einen eigenen Sally Flagship Store zu machen.
Wir haben den Shop so aufgebaut,
dass sich die Menschen wohlfühlen.
Wir haben eins zu eins die Küche
wie bei uns zu Hause aufgebaut.
Die Teppiche sind klein.
An den Wänden erzählen Storys von unseren Produkten.
Hier gibt es KitchenAid. Hier gibt es Kenwood.
Hier gibt es Farben, die es sonst nirgendwo auf der Welt gibt.
Und das ist ein krasses Ding, was wir hier aufgebaut haben.
Auch bei der Dekoration geben wir uns Mühe.
Die Leute sollen beraten werden.
Die bekommen was zu trinken.
Die bekommen auch was zu essen, eine Kleinigkeit.
Und jeder soll sich einfach wohlfühlen bei uns.
Und aus ganz Deutschland kommen sie,
aus Österreich, aus der Schweiz,
aus Teneriffa, aus der Türkei, aus Amerika,
wirklich überallher.
Und so sieht so ein Tisch aus,
toll dekoriert mit viel, viel Liebe.
Das ist jetzt "Mein Mädchentraum in Rosa".
Das ist jetzt nicht mein Fall, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Weil da gibt es auch noch "Männertraum in Schwarz"
mit viel Gusseisen, Messern und allem Drum und Dran.
Hier seht ihr eine Küchenmaschine,
unsere Töpfe,
unsere Teekannen
und unsere Pfannen.
Und es gibt Fische
und zwar die aus Holz.
Aber diese Fische gibt es auch in lebendig.
Das ist auch ein Projekt von uns
und es ist ein Riesenprojekt in Sallycon Valley:
Aquaponik.
Und Aquaponik findet momentan noch in Waghäusel statt.
Es ist eine Testanlage.
Und da würde ich mal gern mit euch hinfahren.
Und was Sally und Sallycon Valley mit Fischen zu tun hat,
sehen wir dann dort, okay?
Also kommt mit.
[Musik]
So.
Das ist ein Projekt unter dem Dach von Sallycon Valley.
Wir nennen es Aquaponik.
Aquaponik, da sind wir schon seit drei Jahren dabei.
Und in diesem Projekt geht es natürlich darum,
die Landwirtschaft und die Fischzucht zu revolutionieren
aus Waghäusel heraus.
Diese Idee kam uns vor drei Jahren.
Da haben wir uns einfach
einen verrückten Professor geschnappt,
weil wir die Idee irgendwo aufgegriffen haben.
Dieser verrückte Professor ist der Herr,
der aussieht Crocodile Dundee da hinten mit dem Hut.
Das ist der Peter.
Warum Aquaponik?
Und zwar: Was haben wir momentan für Probleme
in der Gesellschaft oder auf der Welt?
Immer mehr versiegende Flächen, Wasserflächen,
immer weniger Wasser,
immer weniger landwirtschaftliche Flächen zu bearbeiten.
97% des Wassers auf der Welt
kommt in Salzwasser vor,
das heißt Wasser,
das wir gar nicht für die Landwirtschaft verwenden können.
2% des Wassers, was wir haben auf der Erde,
ist in Seen, im Grundwasser und in Flüssen gebunden.
Und nur 0,6% des Wassers können wir wirklich verwenden.
0,6% des Wassers heißt im Endeffekt:
Wir müssen sparsam mit Wasser,
mit der Ressource Wasser umgehen
und mit der landwirtschaftlichen Fläche.
Über 70% unseres Wasserbedarfes auf der Welt
verwenden wir für die Landwirtschaft
oder für die Weiterverarbeitung von Produkten.
Und wir haben uns gedacht:
Was können wir machen, um hier dieses Problem zu lösen,
dass jeder an Nahrungsmittel herkommt,
dass Nahrungsmittel regional angebaut werden können,
ohne lange Lieferwege, ohne lange Kühlketten?
[Musik]
Unser Ziel ist es,
jedem Menschen auf der Welt,
selbst in Afrika oder in ärmeren Ländern,
den Zugang zu frischen Lebensmitteln und zu Fisch zu geben.
Und das ist so einfach, das Projekt.
Deswegen haben wir ja auch hier
ganz normale HT-Rohre, Europaletten.
Weil das sind Sachen,
die man in jedem Land überall bekommen kann,
keine Hightechware,
sondern wirklich, das kann sich jedes Land,
jedes Dorf irgendwo in Afrika aufbauen.
Und das ist unser Ziel,
die Landwirtschaft zu revolutionieren,
niemandem etwas wegzunehmen,
sondern den Menschen etwas zu geben.
Aquaponik ist was ganz, ganz Einfaches.
Ihr seht ja hier hinten zum Beispiel
– beim Peter seht ihr diese drei Fischtanks.
In diesen Fischtanks befinden sich Fische.
Diese Fische werden von uns gefüttert.
Die machen Kacka ins Wasser.
Das geht zu Boden,
wird durch Bakterien zersetzt
und es entsteht Nitrat.
Und Nitrat ist genau das Mittel,
was Pflanzen zum Wachstum brauchen.
Dann wird es in einen neuen Tank geblasen.
Dort sind die Pflanzen drin
und die nehmen das Nitrat auf und fangen an zu wachsen.
Dadurch machen sie das Wasser auch wieder sauber
und das Wasser kommt in diesen Fischtank wieder
und ist perfekt gereinigt,
dass die Fische wieder drin schwimmen können.
Und das sind solche Projekte,
die wir mit Sallycon Valley machen möchten.
Gerade ist eine riesengroße Aquaponik-Anlage
– dieses Testprojekt hat ungefähr 60 Quadratmeter.
Wir planen eine 10.000-Quadratmeter-Anlage
bei uns in der Region.
Es wird wahrscheinlich die größte Aquaponik-Anlage
in ganz Europa.
Bei uns ist das ganz, ganz wichtig:
Der Weg ist das Ziel.
Auf dem Weg, Aquaponik anzubauen,
die Menschheit zu verändern, auf diesem Weg
passieren viele, viele ganz tolle andere Sachen,
tolle Erfindungen.
Wir werden auch mal scheitern.
Man lernt eher aus Niederlagen als aus Erfolgen.
Und auf diesem Weg
passieren so tolle Geschichten wie hier zum Beispiel.
Hier hatten wir die Idee,
wenn man Basilikum in Unmengen hat
oder zu viel Basilikum hat,
diesen Basilikum zu verarbeiten, zu Pesto zu verarbeiten,
richtig leckeres Pesto.
Und da kam uns eine ganz, ganz neue Idee,
woran wir davor noch gar nicht gedacht haben.
Und das sind diese Geschichten von Aquaponik.
Und was für eine Idee uns da gekommen ist
oder auf was für eine Problematik wir da gestoßen sind,
das würde ich euch mal jetzt gerne in unserer Küche zeigen.
Okay. Kommt mal mit.
[Musik]
So.
Gerade noch in der Aquaponik-Anlage
und jetzt in der heimischen Küche.
Und
was ich euch einfach zeigen möchte, ist, was ich damit meine.
Der Weg ist das Ziel und nicht das Ziel.
Das Ziel ist ganz, ganz klar:
Wir möchten eine Aquaponik-Anlage machen
für eine nachhaltige Fisch-
und eine nachhaltige Gemüsezucht
ohne CO2-Ausstoß.
Und jeder soll es machen können,
selbst in Afrika, selbst in der Türkei,
überall, wo es vielleicht ganz, ganz wenig Wasser hat.
Basilikum kannst du richtig cool
zu einem ganz leckeren Pesto Genovese machen.
Und wenn du es richtig machst,
ist es wirklich zwei bis vier Wochen haltbar.
Und das möchte ich euch zeigen.
Frisch aus dem Garten, frischer geht es wirklich nicht.
Vor zehn Minuten gepflückt.
Wie funktioniert Pesto Genovese?
Vielleicht wird es ja auch irgendwann mal
ein Sally-Pesto geben.
Das weiß ich jetzt noch nicht,
aber wir machen uns jetzt schon die Gedanken.
Und das meine ich damit.
Auf dem Weg passiert sehr, sehr viel.
Ein Pesto Genovese ist ganz easy zu machen.
Das Einzige was ihr braucht, ist:
120 ml Olivenöl,
50 Gramm Parmesankäse,
50 Gramm Pinienkerne,
zwei Knoblauchzehen
– eventuell auch aus der Aquaponik-Anlage –
und Meersalz
– grobes Meersalz nehmen
oder grobes Salz, wenn ihr kein Meersalz habt –
und natürlich 50 Gramm
frischer Pesto – oder Basilikum.
So.
Dann nehmen wir gerade diese Pinienkerne
und tun sie mal richtig cool in der Pfanne anrösten,
das wir mal so ein richtiges Geschmacksaroma,
so ein Röstaroma haben.
Und einfach in die Pfanne schmeißen,
ohne Öl, ohne irgendetwas,
einfach nur anrösten.
[Musik]
So.
Macht euch keine Sorgen.
Ich schaffe das schon.
[Musik]
Wir nehmen jetzt hier das Olivenöl.
Da brauchen wir ungefähr 120 Milliliter.
Das geben wir jetzt rein.
[Musik]
So.
Jetzt haben wir das Olivenöl schon drin.
Jetzt nehmen wir die gerösteten Pinienkerne,
machen sie auch rein.
Zack.
So.
Zwei Knoblauchzehen.
Eventuell, wie gesagt,
jetzt momentan nicht aus der Aquaponik-Anlage.
So.
Dann nehmen wir uns einen Teelöffel Meersalz.
Ihr könnt auch mehr oder weniger Salz.
Das ist je nachdem, was für einen Geschmack ihr habt.
So.
Dann nehmen wir unseren Basilikum
und hauen den Basilikum rein.
So.
>> ELA: Papa?
>> MURAT: Ja, mein Schatz?
Der Papa macht Basilikum.
>> ELA: Aylin?
>> MURAT: So.
Und jetzt lassen wir es einfach kurz laufen, mixen.
So. Jetzt fehlt natürlich
meiner Meinung nach eines der wertvollsten Dinge
bei einem richtigen, coolen Pesto Genovese
und zwar der Parmesankäse.
Jetzt gibt es
– die meisten machen jetzt einen Riesenfehler.
Und zwar: Die schmeißen den Parmesankäse auch rein,
tun den auch mixen.
Aber dann wird das so eine flüssige Masse
und das soll ja schon
ein bisschen eine standhafte Masse sein, das Pesto.
Und da ist der Trick einfach:
Nicht mehr mixen.
Und zwar Folgendes machen.
Zack!
Den Parmesankäse
– ich brauche jetzt 50 Gramm,
macht es einfach aus dem Gefühl heraus –
hier schön
reinmachen.
So. Wie gesagt, den Parmesankäse
– jetzt den Mixer nicht mehr laufen lassen.
Ich habe das Mixmesser rausgemacht.
Jetzt nehme ich so wie so einen Schneebesen.
Oder ihr könnt auch daheim
einen ganz normalen Kochlöffel nehmen,
so was, kurz unterrühren.
Und einfach nur unterrühren.
Ich mache es jetzt einfach so,
zack
und lasse es noch mal richtig schön...
Ihr habt jetzt gesehen:
ganz einfache Zutaten,
ratzfatz und schnell gemacht.
Jetzt kommt gleich der Volkan
– und der Benny.
Und die lasse ich mal vor meinem Sally-
oder halt Murat-Pesto probieren.
Das schmeckt so genial!
Das ist so der Wahnsinn!
Okay.
So.
So. Volkan, kommst du?
>> VOLKAN: Ja.
>> MURAT: Probier mal von meinem...
Volkan, ich habe so ein geniales
– aus Aquaponik so ein geniales Pesto gemacht.
>> VOLKAN: Okay.
>> MURAT: Du wirst
– wirklich, du wirst verrecken.
Das ist der Wahnsinn!
>> VOLKAN: Sorry leider. Ich kann das nicht essen.
Es gibt Käse hier.
>> MURAT: Warum?
>> VOLKAN: Das ist Parmesan.
>> MURAT: Was ist mit dem?
>> VOLKAN: Das ist nicht vegan, das ist vegetarisch.
>> MURAT: Ach!
Ah!
Stimmt. Das ist vegan.
>> VOLKAN: Ich bin vegan.
>> MURAT: Sorry, Volkan.
>> VOLKAN: Sorry.
>> MURAT: Das nächste Mal.
>> VOLKAN: Das nächste Mal.
>> MURAT: Wenn ich einen Baum finde, rufe ich dich. Okay?
>> VOLKAN: Danke.
>> MURAT: Gar kein Thema.
Kann mal
–  Benny?
>> BENNY: Hi!
>> MURAT: Benny. So.
Weißt du was, Benny?
Ich habe ein richtig geniales Pesto
aus unseren Aquaponik-Produkten gemacht.
Und zwar einmal habe ich hier
unser Pesto, was ich selber gemacht habe,
ein Sally-Murat-Pesto,
und ein gekauftes Pesto.
Du darfst jetzt beides probieren und mir sagen,
was besser schmeckt.
>> BENNY: Aber ist das auch vegan?
>> MURAT: Nein.
Habe ich ein Ballettkleid an?
Hä?
>> BENNY: Also
>> MURAT: Hier?
>> BENNY: nee. Das ist aber Käse.
>> MURAT: Käse, ja. Geht nicht bei dir?
>> BENNY: Nee, geht gar nicht.
>> MURAT: Warum?
>> BENNY: Na ja, vegan halt.
>> MURAT: Du bist Veganer?
>> BENNY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Du auch?
Wieso hast du das beim Vorstellungsgespräch nicht gesagt?
>> BENNY: Ja, was hätte denn das geändert?
>> MURAT: Hm.
Für mich schon viel.
Auf jeden Fall, hey, kein Problem.
Wenn...
Weißt du was?
>> BENNY: Hm?
>> MURAT: Ich gehe raus in den Garten und hole
– für Volkan und dich hole ich einfach zwei Äpfel.
Okay? Machen wir es so?
Alles klar.
Danke schön.
So. Jetzt muss ich natürlich irgendjemanden finden, der...
Ben, wenn ich im Kühlschrank noch Methylcellulose finde,
dann mache ich euch ein Pesto daraus. Versprochen.
So.
Auf jeden Fall eine ganz geile Geschichte.
Blöd, jetzt habe ich keinen mehr zum Probieren.
Ich habe nur noch Veganer im Haus.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich da falsch gemacht habe.
So. Auf jeden Fall
haben wir hier einmal das Pesto, was ich gemacht habe.
Hm.
Boah!
Und das Pesto, was man zu kaufen bekommt.
Hm.
Nicht schlecht,
aber ganz klar, meines ist zu 100 Prozent besser.
Und zwar zu 95% sind alle Pestos,
die du im Supermarkt kaufen kannst,
nicht mit Olivenöl, sondern mit Sonnenblumenöl.
Da habe ich mir gedacht: "Boah, krass!
Guck mal. Die sparen wirklich am Olivenöl
und nehmen statt Olivenöl
einfach Sonnenblumenöl."
Das ist natürlich viel, viel günstiger.
Gerade bei dieser Verpackung habe ich gesehen,
die haben
1,9 Liter
– 1,9 Milliliter Olivenöl drin.
Guck mal.
Hier 1,9 Milliliter
und ich habe in meinem Pesto
120 Gramm Olivenöl drin.
Also eine ganz krasse Geschichte.
Ich habe Pinienkerne reingemacht.
Die Industrie macht Cashewkerne rein.
Das ist natürlich auch günstiger.
Die machen Aromen rein.
Die machen Geschmacksverstärker rein.
Und es ist ein frisches Olivenöl.
Und da habe ich mich mal mit einem Chemiker unterhaltenen,
einem Lebensmittelchemiker,
und habe ihm gesagt: "Guck mal.
Ich finde das voll bescheuert.
In Deutschland wird Pesto verkauft
anstatt mit Olivenöl."
Der Deutsche – jetzt wie wir zum Beispiel,
wir würden so ein Pesto nehmen,
wenn wir es angebrochen haben,
in den Kühlschrank reinstellen.
Und wenn es aus Olivenöl ist,
wird Olivenöl hart und es sieht dann ranzig aus.
Und ich zeige ich mal
– ich habe nämlich Olivenöl mal in den Kühlschrank reingetan.
Und ich zeige euch mal, wie das aussieht.
So.
So sieht zum Beispiel Olivenöl aus,
wenn es aus dem Kühlschrank kommt.
Es ist hart geworden.
Das passiert bei Sonnenblumenöl nicht.
So.
Auf jeden Fall,
deswegen tun die wirklich
– tun die beim Industrie-Pesto wirklich
Olivenöl austauschen.
Natürlich ist auch Sonnenblumenöl
– das kostet nur ein Viertel von Olivenöl.
Und dann machen sie ein bisschen Olivenöl rein,
damit es nicht auffällt, dass gar keines drin ist.
1,9 Milliliter ist wirklich so viel.
Und so haben wir uns Gedanken über Olivenöl gemacht.
Was ist eigentlich Olivenöl?
Olivenöl ist das meistgefälschte Lebensmittel auf Erden.
Kein Lebensmittel wird so oft gefälscht wie Olivenöl.
Da gibt es ganz krasse Geschichten.
Und der Murat ist dann wirklich
auf der Spur vom Olivenöl gekommen:
Wo kommt es her?
Was ist die Besonderheit von Olivenöl?
Und das ist der nächste Schritt
auf dem Weg zur Aquaponik eigentlich,
sich nicht nur Gedanken über Pesto zu machen,
sondern auch über Olivenöl.
Und das ist das, was ich sage.
Auf dem Weg zum Ziel passiert so viel.
Das ist wirklich gigantisch.
Und so sind wir eigentlich
zu unserem eigenen Sally-Olivenöl gekommen.
Also vom Basilikum zum Pesto,
vom Pesto zum Olivenöl.
Und da würde ich euch gern eine Geschichte erzählen.
Da würde ich jetzt aber gern
mit euch in unseren Garten gehen,
weil da haben wir wirklich ein Olivenöl
– also kein Olivenöl, sondern einen Olivenbaum.
Und da würde ich euch gern die Geschichte erzählen,
wie es mit unserem Olivenöl weitergeht.
[Musik]
Ja, aus der Küche,
vom Aquaponik,
vom Pesto jetzt zum Olivenöl.
Das ist Sallycon Valley,
einfach Dinge zu machen, die einem Spaß machen.
Und das ist das Besondere, was uns ausmacht,
dass wir wirklich Dinge neu erforschen,
Dinge noch nie gemacht haben.
Ich habe mit Olivenöl gar keine Berührungspunkte gehabt,
mit Pesto auch nicht.
Ich bin eigentlich aus der Baubranche.
Und das Tolle ist an der ganzen Geschichte:
Olivenöl ist was ganz, ganz Besonderes.
Wir stehen gerade hier
oder wir sitzen oder ich sitze hier gerade
unter unserem Olivenbaum aus unserem Garten.
Wir haben einen einzigen.
Der ist schon 300 Jahre alt.
Der hat die Französische Revolution überlebt,
den Ersten Weltkrieg, den Zweiten Weltkrieg
und wird auch mich überleben
und dich wahrscheinlich auch
und uns alle hier.
Auf jeden Fall, Olivenöl ist was ganz, ganz Besonderes.
In der türkischen Kultur natürlich
wird das überall benutzt,
in der italienischen sowieso.
Die Griechen verbrauchen, soweit ich weiß,
42 Liter Olivenöl im Jahr.
Es ist wirklich der Wahnsinn!
In Deutschland leider nur zwei Liter,
weil wir in Deutschland ein bisschen Angst haben vor Olivenöl.
Dabei ist Olivenöl richtig gesund.
Übrigens die gesündesten Menschen
oder die ältesten Menschen der Welt
– der Welt oder sogar,
ich glaube, sogar aus der Welt –
kommen aus Norditalien.
In Italien wird natürlich sehr, sehr viel Olivenöl benutzt,
gutes Olivenöl natürlich.
Olivenöl ist aber auch, wie ich schon erzählt habe,
das meistgefälschte Lebensmittel der Welt.
Ich erkläre es euch ganz, ganz einfach hier.
Ich bin kein Weintrinker.
Das heißt, mit Wein kenne ich mich eigentlich weniger aus.
Ich kriege es immer nur geschenkt.
Ich verschenke es dann weiter.
Und hier haben wir zum Beispiel einen Pfälzer Wein.
Und hier haben wir einen italienischen Wein.
Es sind verschiedene Rebsorten.
Es ist ein Rotwein.
Und kein Winzer würde jemals auf die Idee kommen,
zwei Weinsorten aus verschiedenen Regionen,
von verschiedenen Reben zusammenzumixen
und als Wein zu verkaufen.
Aber das wird leider Gottes bei Olivenöl gemacht.
Da werden einfach Olivenernten
aus verschiedenen Regionen
aus Europa genommen,
aus Österreich
– nicht aus Österreich. Was sage ich?
Österreich hat noch kein Olivenöl,
aber wird langsam kommen.
Der Klimawandel macht es möglich.
Aus Portugal, aus Spanien, aus Italien
werden Olivenernten zusammengesammelt,
verschiedene Olivensorten
– es gibt über 1.000 –
zusammengeworfen, gepresst natürlich
und als Olivenöl aus europäischen Ländern verkauft.
Bitte kauft nicht so ein Olivenöl.
Olivenöl ist wie Wein,
muss aus einer reinen Sorte sein,
richtig gutes Olivenöl aus einer Region
und perfekterweise vielleicht nur aus einem Garten,
nur von einem Hersteller
und nicht von verschiedenen Bauern.
Weil auch der Geschmack kann
– 10, 20 km Entfernung
kann vom Geschmack völlig anders sein.
Die Sonne steht anders.
Es ist ein anderer Boden.
Und deswegen haben wir uns auf die Suche
nach Olivenöl gemacht.
Unser Olivenöl hat übrigens
schon drei Preise in Israel gewonnen.
Wirklich der Wahnsinn!
Denkt mal dran. Sallycon Valley aus Waghäusel
bekommt drei Preise in Israel.
Wirklich der absolute Hammer!
Und...
So.
Wir bleiben direkt im Garten.
Wir bleiben direkt bei uns.
Ich liebe den Garten.
Wir lieben den Garten.
Meine Frau liebt ihn, ich, die Kinder.
Garten ist für uns Erholung.
Und da kommen wir eigentlich zu unserem nächsten Projekt.
Das heißt Restberry Garden.
Genau. Restberry Garden ist ein neues Projekt von uns,
das ich euch gern vorstellen würde.
Aber dazu gehen wir zu unseren Hochbeeten
und da erzähle ich euch alles darüber.
[Musik]
Hier sind wir bei uns am Hochbeet.
Ihr habt in den letzten Jahren oftmals mitverfolgen können,
wie wir Hochbeete gebaut haben,
wie wir Kräuter gepflanzt haben,
Bäume zurechtgeschnitten haben
oder den Rollrasen gelegt haben.
Garten ist für uns einfach Leben.
Das gehört zu uns dazu genauso wie die Küche.
Und ihr habt schon die Projekte gesehen,
die großen Projekte, Aquaponik.
Das kann die Welt verändern.
Doch wir haben uns überlegt:
Was kann man denn zu Hause verändern?
Was kann man auf dem Balkon verändern,
am Grundstück, neben dem Haus oder im Schrebergarten?
Und wir wollen das coole Urban Gardening machen,
selbst zu Hause Dinge anpflanzen.
Ihr seht hier zum Beispiel Blutampfer.
Da habt ihr Sauerampfer.
Dann habt ihr hier Petersilie, Schnittlauch.
Dann haben wir hier Kürbis.
Der wächst wie Unkraut.
Und das ist alles so einfach zu machen.
Und einfach hier zum Nachbarn rüberwerfen.
Das sind auch wir. Wir sind auch die Nachbarn gleich.
Und dazu haben wir
die Marke Restberry Garden ins Leben gerufen.
Restberry Garden ist ein cooler Brand rund um den Garten.
Da geht es wirklich um Pflanzen.
Da geht es um eigene Bäume,
um coolere Sorten
und natürlich auch Werkzeug made in Germany,
direkt hier aus Waghäusel.
Und Restberry Garden
– Garten ist wirklich Lifestyle.
Garten ist übrigens auch richtig sexy.
Es ist auch voll easy.
Einfach ein Loch machen.
Zack.
Den Basilikum andrücken.
[Musik]
So. Und das ist mein eigener Basilikum.
Der wird jetzt richtig anwachsen.
Und daraus können wir wieder richtig eigenes Pesto machen,
so wie ich es vorhin in der Küche gemacht habe.
Und jetzt kommt noch eins drüber.
Wisst ihr, was das hier ist?
Pinguinkacke ist richtiges Gold.
Das ist ein richtig cooles Triebmittel.
Das machen wir jetzt noch drauf.
Ein bisschen Wasser.
Zack. Und das war es schon.
[Musik]
Und wisst ihr, was auch richtig sexy ist?
Sexy ist, einen eigenen Garten zu haben
mit eigenem Obst und eigenem Gemüse,
also richtig coole Äpfel direkt vom Baum runter zu essen,
richtig coole Birnen.
Keine Kühlketten, keine langen Lieferwege,
das ganze Jahr über.
Und da gehen wir mal in meinen natürlichen Supermarkt.
Der ist nämlich dahinten.
Da gehen wir jetzt nämlich kurz zusammen hin.
[Musik]
Wie ein eigener Supermarkt, oder?
Äpfel,
Birnen.
Ja, Birnen, Äpfel, Trauben, Himbeeren,
alles gibt es bei uns hier im Garten.
Und alles kann es auch bei euch im Garten geben.
Deswegen haben wir diese Marke
Restberry Garden gegründet.
Das wird eine ganz tolle Geschichte.
Natürlich geht es auch um Bäume,
seltene Arten, seltene Sorten, besondere Sorten
zu züchten, euch zu zeigen.
Und natürlich geht es auch ein bisschen um Lifestyle.
Lifestyle – zum Beispiel coole Workwear,
tolle Kleidung, die wir zusammen machen werden.
Und bei dieser Kleidung, da gibt es was ganz, ganz Tolles,
das würde ich euch gern zeigen.
Da müssen wir aber rein ins Gebäude.
Und...
Ups! Ja?
>> GÜNTER: Habe ich dir schon gesagt, dass du aussiehst
wie ein kleiner osmanischer Gartenzwerg?
>> MURAT: Bitte hört nicht auf ihn.
Wir gehen jetzt rein
und ich zeige euch mal zum Thema Kleidung
jetzt was ganz, ganz Cooles:
Manooka.
Und was das ist, dazu gehen wir rein.
Güni, warte mal kurz.
Hier hast du einen Apfel.
Ups!
Da musst du aufpassen.
So.
Kein Problem, geht rüber.
Güni, da.
>> GÜNTER: Der reißt den halben Baum ab.
[Musik]
>> MURAT: So. Jetzt sind wir im Kinderzimmer
von der Samira.
Und die Samira macht gerade was.
Und zwar: Gerade sind Ferien.
Sie hat ihr Zeugnis bekommen.
Und zum Zeugnis hat sich was gewünscht
und zwar eine Nähmaschine.
Samira malt gerne, sie kocht gerne
und sie näht gern Kleidung selber.
Guck mal. Hier hat sie zum Beispiel ein Kissen gemacht.
Was ist das, Samira?
>> SAMIRA: Ich mache gerade eine Handytasche für Mama.
>> MURAT: Ah okay. Sie macht eine Handytasche.
Guck mal. Und Kinder sollten das aus Spaß heraus machen,
also wirklich, weil sie was damit lernen möchten.
Und Kinder sollten das nicht daraus machen,
um einen Lebensunterhalt zu verdienen.
Und dazu kommen wir zum nächsten Projekt.
Nähmaschine und Kinder
– was könnte das natürlich sein?
Kleidung.
Die Kleidungs- und die Textilindustrie
ist die zweitdreckigste Industrie der Welt,
nach der Ölindustrie.
Und wir haben uns gedacht,
da müssen wir unbedingt was ändern.
Und so kamen wir auf die Idee Manooka.
Manuka ist ja vielleicht jemandem von euch ein Begriff.
Das ist der beste Honig aus Neuseeland,
saumäßig teuer.
Und wir haben uns überlegt,
Manuka ist genial auch als Namensgeber
für unsere Kinderkleidung.
Und zwar möchten wir Kinderkleidung produzieren.
Allein in Baden-Württemberg
wird im Monat über 100 Fußballfelder
Textilien oder halt Stoffe weggeschmissen
aus Überproduktion,
wirklich Stoffe, die für Kollektionen vielleicht zu klein sind.
Und diese Kollektionen, diese Stoffe sammeln wir ein
und machen in Pfullingen daraus
– wirklich in Deutschland, made in Germany –
Kinderkleidung.
>> DEAN: Hi, Sally! Hi, Murat!
Liebe Grüße nach Waghäusel
vom Fuße der Schwäbischen Alb.
Ich bin in der Produktion.
Wir arbeiten echt auf Hochtouren.
Wir sind gerade an der Fertigstellung der Musterteile.
Dann werde ich euch alles mal zeigen.
Wie gesagt, hier läuft alles auf Hochtouren.
Und ich würde euch jetzt einfach mal kurz entführen,
dort, wo die Magie sozusagen passiert.
Weil wir machen da ja kein Geheimnis daraus,
wo wir produzieren und was wir produzieren.
Überzeugt euch da einfach mal selber davon.
[Musik]
>> MURAT: Und das ist das Tolle,
was wir mit Manooka machen möchten:
Arbeitsplätze schaffen.
Und ich sage immer:
Kinderkleidung soll von Erwachsenen
für Kinder gemacht werden
und nicht von Kindern für Kinder.
Und deswegen ist es Manooka.
Mit den Erlösen von Manooka unterstützen wir unsere Stiftung
und wir machen Projekte für Kinder.
Also es ist richtig eine geniale Geschichte, Manooka.
Und
ihr habt es gesehen,
Manooka heißt auch so richtig coole Kleidung.
Ihr seht
– hier ist so ein Bäbber noch drauf.
Richtig coole Formen, richtig coole Schnitte.
Auch so Mini-Mes,
wo die Eltern die gleichen Klamotten anziehen wie die Kinder.
Und das alles made in Pfullingen.
Das ist was richtig Geniales!
Und jetzt habt ihr gesehen:
Aquaponik, ein nachhaltiges Projekt.
Restberry Garden,
das ist was fürs Herz aus dem Garten heraus.
Manooka für unsere Stiftung
und einfach coole Arbeitsplätze schaffen in Deutschland.
Und das alles geschieht in Sallycon Valley.
Und genau da sollten wir eigentlich jetzt hinfahren.
Wobei hinfahren was richtig Doofes ist,
weil eigentlich müssen wir ja nur einmal um den Zaun laufen.
Und das machen wir.
Und ich zeige euch Sallycon Valley und was dort geschieht.
It all starts in your head.
No matter where you are.
Das ist Englisch.
Das hört sich einfach cooler an als Deutsch.
Auf Deutsch ganz einfach:
Es ist egal, wo du bist,
ob du in einem kleinen Dorf bist, in einem kleinen Büro,
irgendwo auf dem Land, auf einem Bauernhof.
Es reicht die Idee,
um etwas zu erreichen,
und mutig zu sein.
Und ihr habt gesehen, wir machen ganz, ganz viele Projekte,
weil wir einfach mutig sind.
Aus der kleinen Studentenküche,
aus dem kleinen Kinderzimmer ist etwas Tolles entstanden.
Und die Leute trauen uns inzwischen auch einiges zu.
Vielleicht werden wir das Wasserstoffauto hier drin finden,
hier in Waghäusel,
oder die Welt verändern.
Wir trauen uns etwas zu und wir haben den Mut,
Dinge neu zu denken und neu zu machen.
Und wie es jetzt gerade aussieht
– gehen wir mal hin und schauen es uns mal an.
[Musik]
So sieht es gerade auf dem Bau aus.
Normalerweise wären wir schon fertig,
aber ich denk mal, so in zwei Monaten
sind wir in der Endphase.
Dann werden hier ganz, ganz viele
neue Arbeitsplätze entstehen,
tolle Berufe, die es hier in der Region
vielleicht noch gar nicht hatte.
Und wie gesagt,
unsere Idee ist, euch zu überraschen.
Danke, dass ihr euch das ganze Video angeschaut habt.
Das Haus allgemein wird sehr, sehr energetisch gebaut.
Aber dazu werden noch weitere Videos folgen,
vom Bau, von Sallycon Valley.
Begleitet uns einfach weiter.
Träumt mit uns.
Träumen darf man ja.
Und, wie gesagt, die Gedanken sind frei.
Und das, was du dir ausdenken kannst,
das kannst du auch erreichen.
Vielen Dank. Macht's gut!
Euer Murat
Ich muss jetzt auf den Bau und Güni weiterhelfen.
[Musik]